il
je
bonjour à tous je suis c'est cool et etc
tech
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de l'onu
alors qu'est ce que l'onu l'onu qui
signifie organisation des nations unies
a été créée après la seconde guerre
mondiale plus précisément le 26 juin
1945 à san francisco lors de l'entrée au
vigueur de la charte des nations unies
mais la création officielle de l'onu et
le 24 octobre 1945
combien de pays ont signé le texte
fondateur de l'onu les pays fondateurs
de l'onu sont au nombre de 51 pour être
parmi ces 51 pays
la condition effective était d'avoir
déclaré la guerre à l'allemagne nazie au
moins trois mois avant sa capitulation
et combien y at-il aujourd'hui depuis
membres l'onu compte actuellement 193
états membres à part entière sur les 197
qu'elle reconnaît en effet les quatre
états reconnus mais nos membres sont le
vatican la palestine quand si que les
îles cook any way dans l'océan pacifique
sud
quels sont les objectifs de l'onu les
objectifs de l'onu étaient au nombre de
quatre à sa création
maintenir la paix et la sécurité dans le
monde développé entre les nations des
relations amicales réaliser la
coopération internationale en résolvant
les problèmes internationaux d'ordre
économique social intellectuel et
humanitaires en développant et en
encourageant le respect des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
pour tous sans distinction de race de
sexe de langue ou de religion
être enfant trousses harmonise les
efforts des nations vers ces objectifs
communs depuis 1972
l'onu a également comme objectif la
protection de l'environnement
l'onu n'est pas d'un gouvernement
mondial et ne promulgue donc pas de loi
elle vote des résolutions qui donne une
légitimité aux interventions des états
et elles sont de plus en plus appliquée
dont le droit international et national
ou 6e l'onu le siège de l'onu est à new
york sur un territoire international ce
qui veut dire par exemple qu'aucune
intervention américaine le petit avoir
lieu sans la permission du secrétaire
général de l'onu
cinq des six organes principaux de l'onu
siège est à new york
seule la cour internationale de justice
siège à la haye aux pays bas
quant aux nombreuses agences de l'onu
beaucoup siège est à genève
l'unesco dont nous parlerons plus tard à
son siège à paris que l'on parle t-on à
l'onu l'onu à six langues officielles le
français l'anglais l'arabe l'espagnol le
russe et le mondarrain les deux langues
de travail sont l'anglais et le français
on parle souvent du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu de quoi s'agit-il
le conseil de sécurité est responsable
du maintien de la paix et de la sécurité
dont le monde
il est composé de quinze états membres
dont cinq sont permanents et dispose
d'un droit de veto
ce sont les états unis la grande
bretagne la russie la chine la france
bonjour les dix autres états membres du
conseil de sécurité sont élus par
l'assemblée générale pour deux ans qu'il
est devenu l'onu et dirigée par son
assemblée générale où tous les états
membres sont représentés et dispose
d'une voix
depuis 2007 c'est le sud-coréen ban
ki-moon qui est le secrétaire général
des nations unies j'espère que vous avez
bien compris ce qu'est l'onu
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode